so many things are on the table when it
comes to helping conserve water so what
about home swimming pools they're
thinking about that the Las Vegas Valley
Water District voting today to limit the
construction size of New Pools to 600
square feet Jeremy J Ford explains those
changes
across the valley with summer
temperatures averaging well into the
triple digits Property Owners may be
looking to get a pool to cool off but
now they may have to rethink the size
this feels like it's one of the things
we have to do the Las Vegas Valley Water
District is concerned about water
conservation that 600 square foot size
limit is expected to save 3.2 million
gallons of water every year John
inspinger oversees the water district
and the Southern Nevada Water Authority
no one industry is being singled out
everyone is being asked to make
sacrifices so that if we can get our
water use down to that 86 gallons per
capita right now the water district
argues many pools in the valley exceed 3
000 square feet and are just four looks
Kevin Craft of Aussie craft pools makes
his money building luxury pools he tells
me there's a better solution to the
problem which includes a conservation
they could be paid if someone wanted to
go over that they would pay a
substantial conservation fee because as
it stands he's already lost the client
we already know of 150 million dollar
project that was scrapped from today's
meeting it's a rather large contract
that's that's no longer on our books
Jeremy J Ford live local now
the Southern Nevada Water Authority says
millions of gallons of Lake Mead water
could be saved each year it also
recommends getting a pool covered or to
cut down on the evaporation the 600
square foot limit by the way would go
into effect September 1st